and finally new rules sometimes
bipartisanship isn't the solution it's
the problem you might be surprised at
how many times the far left and the far
right otherwise known as the right
actually work together to make a problem
worse for example they both resist
globalization the far left because it
can exploit workers the far right
because their country music station
switched to Mexican right and left have
bonded and believing 9/11 was an inside
job somehow the leftist like Oliver
Stone and a wannabe dictator like Trump
both think Putin is a great guy and then
there's something I like to call the
bipartisan pro fat movement despite the
fact that obesity accounts for 18
percent of the deaths in America and a
huge chunk of our health care bill and
is the main reason people wear
sweatpants in public and I'm working now
got to [ __ ] up everybody in liberal
circles the worst thing anyone can ever
do is mention weight because that's not
shaming and to conservatives any attempt
to even offer guidelines about what to
eat well that smells like social
engineering as opposed to freedom which
smells like bacon now you remember the
write was infuriated back when first
lady Michelle Obama was trying to impose
her radical Black Panther agenda
encouraging kids to eat healthy Sarah
Palin went so far as to defiantly show
up at a school with plates of sugar
cookies that'll teach you kids to eat a
carrot
how did vegetables get to be unamerican
ok super Patriots eat what you want but
let's get let's get real these colors
don't run because these colors can't run
[Applause]
but the rotund right is not alone in
promoting tolerance of a national health
crisis back when they both had jobs
Steve Bannon was asked why Sean Spicer
was spending less time in front of the
camera and he joked oh well Sean got
fatter okay not the greatest joke ever
but a joke not not to Chelsea Clinton it
wasn't she tweeted fat shaming isn't a
joke I find funny ever no Christ even
your mom knew when to fake a laugh
I'm sorry but pretending everyone is
beautiful at any size is not helping
them it's enabling them but among the
shaming police the most important
message you could ever send an obese
person is that your body is perfect just
the way it is prone on a gurney you know
I'm right [ __ ] using head like you
see headlines on liberal websites like
body positivity has no size limit really
no limit at all there's no middle ground
between shaming and Shamu but wait it
gets worse
not only are left and right United on
what goes in your mouth
they've also declared open season on the
words that come out of it
free speech is under attack from both
sides you have Trump who says news so
many times a day it's like he has
totalitarian Tourette's a president an
American president calling the Fourth
Estate the enemy he's also called them
scum disgusting really good people and
he wants to change libel law so he can
go after people who insult him and in
his words sue the wood loads of money he
tried it with me four years ago to the
tune of five million dollars simply
because I demanded he produced you
remember this his birth certificate and
prove he wasn't part orange-haired
orangutan
hey a lot of people were saying it a lot
of people were saying and then there's
what's going on on the left oh we have
our own anti-free speech brigade which
you might know by their other name
college we're the most popular major
these days is outraged with a minor in
canceling speaking engagements Berkeley
was the home of the free speech movement
now it's enforcing speaking bands it's
like the Catholic Church enforcing an
age of consent so there you have it next
time someone pines for bipartisanship
just remember when people of goodwill
come together across the aisle we can
[ __ ] up anything